what gets measured gets improved and in
this video we're going to be talking
about how to maximize your youtube
analytics to get more views and a really
cool tool that makes the
complication and the kind of sometimes
overwhelming nature
of youtube analytics really simple but i
want to give you four questions you
should ask every time you look at your
youtube analytics the first question is
what videos are performing best right
you want to look at your youtube
analytics
ask yourself which videos are doing best
so that i could actually make more of
those videos the second question is what
videos can i make today
that will keep working for me tomorrow
like which of my older videos are still
doing well because there's clearly
something powerful about the topics of
those videos or the content of those
videos that i should do more of
so that i can continue to get videos
working for me when i'm not
working you know this cool tool i'm
going to share with you in a second
though helps because honestly the
youtube studio does not do a good job of
showing us older content that is
performing well in an easy to understand
way but that's some information you're
going to want to dig out now what are my
older videos that are doing well that
are working for i made them yesterday
but they're still working for me uh in
the future the third question is what
videos from my competitors are
performing best
is there something that i can find on a
competitor's channel
that's doing well so that i can react to
that video or cover a similar topic or
maybe get inspired by their ideas and do
my own version of it
and then the fourth question is what
topics
and content should i stop doing like
which videos are doing
not very well and there may be a waste
of my time or if they're really not
helping me grow or even worse i'm losing
subscribers from those topics i should
stop doing that if i want to actually
make positive progress with my youtube
channel and so those are four questions
you should ask we're going to get to the
tool in just a second but smash like if
you're getting value out of this video
so far this is the coffee with cannell
show my name is sean cannell and i'm
super fired up to have you here live
with me today or if you're watching this
on the replay let's get straight into
this and actually what we're going to be
talking about today is the vid iq
channel audit tool so if you actually
want to study your youtube analytics in
an easy way
the vid iq channel audit tool which
you're going to love i'm going to show
you it in just a second
is such a cool way of making of taking
the complexity out of youtube analytics
so
today's stream is brought to you by
vidiq and if you don't have the iq
installed yet check out a link in the
description down below you can go to
vidiq.com
forward slash think and that's going to
give you a free 30-day paid plan of
their
of any of the vid iq plans
the free version you definitely want to
get it
install vidiq vision which is a google
chrome plugin and that's where you can
get access to all of these cool suite of
tools
but also there's some very powerful
things that are unlocked in the
paid version and so we're going to be
talking about that and one of those is
the channel audit tool and so let's look
at what the channel audit tool is and
you can start seeing how you can study
your analytics in such a powerful way
now this
is the think media youtube channel and
this is what you'll see when you log in
into the back end of your analytics but
if you notice here on the left side of
the screen
you'll see content playlist analytics
comments subtitles copyright you'll see
all this stuff right but then you'll
also see these vid iq logo
options that get added once you install
vid iq
and get the vidiqvision plugin things
like the daily ideas tool which is
incredible that'll give you daily ideas
keyword inspector but we're going to
focus on one tool today and that is the
channel audit tool which is right above
my little picture-in-picture screen here
on the video so when i click that tool
this opens up what is called the channel
audit tool which is a super
user-friendly
dashboard
that actually gives us some really cool
insights
into how we can improve the content on
our youtube channel now the first thing
that
i want to focus on here is tip number
one and that is content to double down
on so if you ask yourself when studying
analytics right what you want to ask
yourself
is
after i've posted some videos on my
channel
which content what type of topics what
type of titles what about video
thumbnails or whatever what should
better what's working well that i should
do more of
and so
this is this first section content to
double down on now there's kind of a
unique
aspect of this tool because right now
we're looking in the last
30 days
of content we should double down on and
we see
that the desk tour i recently did did
well
that um we see some of our
mainly our newer videos are doing really
well uh nolan did a video on netflix
revealing secrets we can use on youtube
and
uh what i what's cool though is that in
some cases
uh
in our content to double down on there's
views per hour that's v ph that's view
velocity and there's a little i that
explains what that means
this is videos with the highest views
per hour
you should double down on these and
create more videos like these so we
should create more videos about the m50
or the sony zve10 we should create more
desk tours we should cover the gopro
hero 10 more it's funny though we did a
video though where people could download
30 funny sound effects for their video
for their videos and this video is a
little bit older and
what you can do is maybe you want to see
remember one of my questions was what
videos did i make a while ago that are
still doing good today
but what's cool about this tool is we
can go up here and say limit to videos
in the time frame and see now it's going
to delete anything that is a little bit
older right notice how it changes the
results and this is powerful because the
actual youtube analytics don't really
give you these nuanced options now i
actually kind of like seeing
videos from any time on the channel
because some of the other ways you could
measure success is
engagement rate that's going to be
comments and likes views but also
subscribers gained so let's say maybe
you're like i want to get my first 1 000
subscribers i want to get my first 10
000 or 100 000 subscribers
certain types of videos
are actually growing the channel
the most by certain subscribers in this
case
one of the videos that's growing uh the
channel the most is actually pretty old
it's a video i made about is it too late
to start youtube quite a while ago but
if i actually just want to study my
channel in regards to the last
30 days i can do that by checking this
box in the upper right hand corner
pretty cool and then the second aspect
is i also maybe don't want to just look
at content to double down on in the last
30 days in fact i would recommend
that um a lot of times we look at a
wider
time frame 30 days isn't necessarily
enough time for videos to mature in fact
a youtube employee that was speaking at
vidsummit recently taught
he was saying that don't judge a video
by the first day week or even month
youtube especially if you're creating
content that can be evergreen that can
be relevant for a long time and have a
long shelf life it's actually nice to
judge it by a lot longer of a window of
time call it 60 days
um or even 90. and so uh we are now
looking let me reset this so we get all
the right screens on
the screen
we're going to channel audit tool
we are
me zooming it in kind of tweaked it okay
let me get back to 100 here
and so um i would suggest that we look
at more like
30 days 60 days in terms of our viewing
back in history
to
see content that we
should double down on but let's get into
tip number
two here
and that is also top search terms so in
addition to what videos should i make
the next question is also what are the
top search terms
that could bring traffic into my
channel and so um
we now let's let's finish up on that
60-day window time frame
and uh
we'll do 90 next this will start really
telling us okay what videos from
yesterday
and
maybe limit to videos in that time frame
what videos from the last 90 days have
done the best and that should absolutely
inform the next couple videos
i
produce
and so as we look back this is
interesting in terms of views when we
talked about the atm mini
um
and that actually kind of surprised us
omar talked about that we definitely and
tony's helping me in the back end here
uh we should actually probably double
down on this device because it actually
is very popular and uh this kind of
signifies there's interest there so
that's kind of a real-time insight i'm
getting right now out of using um this
tool but now as we scroll down remember
tip number two here is top search terms
so
again the point of the channel audit
tool it just makes it really easy
to quickly make data-driven decisions
about what to do next now our funny
sound effects video is crushing so
that's when people search for funny
sounds that led to 91 000
um
i would assume clicks and views and
it'll tell us here here are your highest
ranking keywords
um that and then if you click on it by
the way right it's going to take you
over to the actual traffic
and this is now into your youtube studio
proper so the search term funny sounds
has led to 91 000 views on think media
the next one over here is how to edit
videos so again this is this is back in
your youtube advanced features so you
could find that data but here on the
channel audit tool it's just making it
really easy and saying okay
here's the top
search terms for the last 90 days
how to edit your videos
funny sound effect how to create a
youtube channel
sound effects how to make a youtube
channel so we already have nolan has
other sound effects videos in the key
queue
but um
it
is so clear as we're looking at this
um the types of videos how to make a
video how to edit a video
and oh admittedly
like it's been a while since we've made
videos with those titles you know
success leaves clues make part twos
identify the biggest opportunities that
are generating the most traffic most
impact in your video library and make
more of those make a new version make an
updated version of those that's what
we're discovering by using this tool to
make data driven decisions and then one
other thing that's kind of unique here
is we're seeing not just our views but
also the amount of watch time because
remember views are important but minutes
matter most
so some of these
uh
topics are going to lead to a lot more
watch time especially our editing
tutorials are definitely the type of
videos that people dwell on whereas the
sound effects one are actually videos
that people are just downloading like a
lot of times we'll just like rip the
video off youtube or they'll download
the sound effects if we throw them on
dropbox or something like that and so
that is tip number two we're going to
study our top search terms
now next this one's really important so
lean in for this and hit the like button
if you're getting value we study our top
suggested
videos non-owned
so here's what this means
this
means which videos
are giving you the most suggested
traffic
so
all of this first section is content to
double down on the second section we'll
get to it is content that could use some
work okay
so
if we look here
on the right side of this tool
it says top suggested non-owned
so what videos
are
sending
think media the most views here are the
top suggests suggesting your content we
suggest making similar content and study
the correlation and then double down so
see these little talk bubbles are going
to tell you exactly how you should
interpret this information
and
this list is now the videos that are
suggesting
the most traffic to think media now this
top one is no surprise since i am on
think media this is actually a video
from video influencers
that is sending the most traffic then we
see my friend justin brown
brown here one of his videos about how
to create a youtube channel sending
traffic
shelby church here what youtubers don't
tell you about starting a channel
um what this shows me right here is
number one i like a couple things i love
her thumbnail it's very creative kind of
creative text on there holding the two
cameras
that inspires me like again i don't want
to copy shelby but i want to kind of
dovetail off of that like like an indy
500 race you know or like a nascar
you know kind of race where you're
you're dr you're drafting that's the
idea of looking at suggested as saying
okay there's a correlation here
what can i and by the way this also
tells me i should go check out shelby
church's channel look at what videos
have been performing best on her channel
lately or some topics that might inspire
mine because by the way her her things
that youtubers don't tell you about
starting a channel are also going to be
different than mine like straight up i
i'm going to take that exact
title right i'm going to
uh potentially use that and i think
that's that's an amazing idea what
youtubers don't tell you about starting
a channel so then we have some of the
videos on the actual youtube creator
channel
uh film booth over here on some
monetization stuff so you see how
powerful this list is like this right
here it shows you that this tool can
instantly really get you crushing in
terms of
um
what content you should double down on
and that is
the top video suggesting
views to your channel next
end screen and card click rates
so as we keep going deeper in our
channel audit tool here we can actually
see we're looking in the last 90 days
we can actually see
our end screen click rates and our card
click
through rates so first of all
i want you to be using end screens
cards are maybe less important but they
can be important we recommend we had a
thick media uh overrated underrated
session with tony and omar and heather
and we talked about uh you know how
important are cards because sometimes
cards can distract or people don't click
them but end screens are a big deal and
when it comes to creating a youtube end
screen during the last 20 seconds of
your video you have options to select a
specific video
to select a playlist of videos to let
youtube choose a video that would be
best for your viewer
to select a recent upload
or to send traffic to a channel or
something else now of course the
click-through rate is going to be
influenced by what you say and what you
promote
but here's what i can learn when i check
in on this
i can actually learn that
the best performing
uh end screen click-through rate for us
at seven percent which is really good
is
a
specific video and that is a power tip
right in the middle of the stream that i
would highly recommend
um leaning in on
when you end your youtube video
think about what would be the best video
for people to watch next and verbally
lead them to a specific video second to
that is
a playlist
because it's to say if you want to watch
other videos in our m50 series
click or tap the screen to watch that
right now
interestingly enough the best for viewer
this is also contrary to what i used to
recommend in the past the best for
viewer
click-through rate
maybe tells us that youtube isn't as
good as we think in terms of picking out
a video they actually care about when
someone's done on their video like the
chance of them just clicking an end card
because like oh i'm just going to
randomly click that like that entices me
i think the unlock is
you want to
to a degree control the viewer journey
you just watched this video friend
this is where you should go next check
out this video next click or tap the
screen and by letting youtube just
uh
pick that it's not necessarily or recent
upload it's significantly
lower of a click-through rate and then
we also see of course
this is going to be ineffective if
you're not using these but playlists
videos i mean 28
people clicking on playlists and that
would probably be very specific if
you're
very effective if you're making video
series
so they're a part of a video that you're
watching right now and on the card you
link to other videos in the series and
they're like i want to jump into the
whole series then that is an opportunity
there so i'm using the vid iq channel
tool
uh channel audit tool i'm
using this in my review of my analytics
and i'm looking for insights so that i
can optimize videos maybe optimize some
of the end cards add some cards
think about have i updated my playlist
by the way i'm all of these reminders
are coming as i'm going through this
channel audit tool right now as well as
okay let me go check out shelby church
what what can i learn there um what are
some of the other suggested videos i
could double down on and what videos
should i ultimately make next
um
five look for themes and patterns
the big idea
as we are inside of our channel audit
tool
is to look for themes look for patterns
one of the big insights we just talked
about as the team
was how well
general home office accessories and home
office desk tours are going so uh that
was a conversation this morning those
types of insights can come out of
here one of the things i sent to omar
recently was i said omar you have the
top retention video on our channel a 98
point
uh
three five percent retention almost 100
retention
so themes and patterns what can i learn
about this video let's rewatch it let's
restudy this video to think about why
was retention so good how long was the
video how how often were the cuts in the
video
if a lot of youtube shorts doing well in
regards to
uh retention which doesn't shouldn't
surprise us but it's an encouragement to
uh double down on some of those youtube
shorts maybe how long is the short one
myth people make about youtube shorts is
thinking you need to do 60 seconds
you could do four seconds you could do
go back to anybody remember vine let me
know in the comments through back to
vine days seven second youtube shorts
like really thinking about short form
content not only may you get 100
retention you can start getting over 100
like people watch it multiple times
because it's a really cool video or
really cool
whatever it is you ultimately create and
so we're looking for themes and patterns
what are the themes what are the
patterns that can give me guidance on
where i should steer my channel next
tip number six is you want to switch up
the time frame as we discussed
so what's cool about this is as we're
getting all these insights we may want
to switch up the time frame to 60 days
and then we may want to also say i only
want to study videos in the last 60 days
we have a ton of videos that are
historic so we click limit videos to
time frame and then say okay
which videos are growing the channel the
most subscribers
which videos are getting the top
retention now in just the last 60 days
which playlists are performing best
in the last 60 days by messing with the
time frame you can actually get better
insights and more insights and then tip
number seven look at i got one more tip
for you and then we'll get into the
coffee with candle q and a all and all
of that stuff is what are the top videos
by competitors i could spend so much
time on this one this one's super fun um
and so one of my favorite things about
vid iq
and um remember today's video is brought
to you by vidiq especially when you
could get a 30-day free trial on the
boost plan when you get into the boost
plan
you have the ability to
study your competitors and analyze your
competitors
and there's a whole web-based aspect of
vidiq and i'll show you that where
um
you are essentially seeing a
cool dashboard
this is this is deeper than the vid iq
vision aspect of of the tool
and uh
on the
app.vidiq.com
you could see that i am studying here
other people in our industry and
specifically you know and and when i say
competitors look i mean a lot of these
are my friends um you know roberto and
daryl and tim
but what's cool is we can look on this
dashboard here this isn't the channel
audit tool and see
some insights in terms of how how are
their views going in the last 60 days
the last 12 months
um you know this is think media right
here on the right side in terms of the
last 12 months pretty cool 45 million
views it's pretty gnarly
um everyday dad you know we look from a
tech side a couple other justin browns
over here and you know catherine and so
you you can look at that data but what i
want you to see
is right over here confetti competitors
by
views per hour
so
right now we can really look okay
these are the competitors that i've
selected and i want to see the top
ranked
videos
in regards to
that are getting crazy vph views per
hour
and of course probably in if you follow
tech the m1 macbook or the iphone 13.
but honestly like i'm out here omar got
this this iphone 13 mini and tony you
might want to screenshot this to be like
bro so you know like that's it's just
kind of clear like success leaves clues
and and that would be
you know
one of our promises on think media is to
help
the best tips and tools for creators
especially two on a budget and so that's
not even the pro max right that's the
that's the bottom of the line iphone
that i think is like seven or eight
hundred dollars which i know is still
it's much more affordable than like two
grand for the one terabyte pro max 13
right so anyways like huge insight
because when there's a lot of velocity
that's something to double down on maybe
we talk about the the new m1 macbooks
but as we go deeper of course our very
friends and rob at vid iq
uh
missed opportunity really good thumbnail
there
it could inspire some content that we do
next really great title
um
and we can look through okay what else
is on here
uh
we could look at so there's some
information about business
how to cut out background noises from
your video calls really good idea and
that's a short um and and we have just
other insight in general a case study an
interview of of someone that somebody
tim had somebody on
making 25k in six months on youtube
after six years with no results so what
am i looking for
title formats
opportunities of how could we
um if i started my business over what
would i do differently that's kind of
like the shelby church model
like
if i started think media over what would
i do differently right and i think you
get it
i mean i'm copying vanessa
but i'm not copying i mean it's a it's a
format she just created a framework for
me
my answers are not gonna be the same as
her
and it's it's a legit it's a really cool
question like it actually gets me
thinking like what would i do if i
started my business over what are the
five things boom and that is a video
that's going well for her i might study
it and then that influences what video i
should make next my friends
if you really want to start driving more
results in your channel really consider
um
making better topics
you got to level up your strategy
get better insights get better clarity
get better data and have that influence
and level up your strategy all right tip
number eight hit like if you've been
getting value
is also what practical things should i
fix
and update we're using the vid iq
channel audit tool
and
in addition to
i kind of skipped over it but here's
another tip in the middle content that
could use some work
this is gonna help
us review this probably even maybe more
influential or or more powerful than
content to double down on
because i can see that my multi-stream
camera video
had
is it holds the record in the last you
know 60 days for the lowest average
watch time
so
that can influence editing that can
influence maybe i'm a little long-winded
that can influence what about that video
maybe didn't hold retention so we have
lowest retention lowest watch time
lowest views videos losing subs what
videos are actually triggering the
greatest loss of subscribers and then
remember you can always click on these
go deeper and say okay
what are the videos for worst average
watch time now let me also encourage you
this is not meant
to
um
lead you to a place of discouragement or
lead you to a place of i'm a failure or
lead you a place because this is this is
the failure list though if we're honest
you know what i mean like like but
notice there's also tension here because
even though this has a lowest average
wasp watch time it says over here it's
top top two in views and sometimes when
a video starts getting suggested getting
more views it'll drive down the watch
the average view time a little bit
because it's just it's going to more
people and they're not going to watch as
long they're skipping around youtube but
nevertheless with a healthy a healthy
self-image and healthy self-confidence i
do want you to consider
digging into
man how could i maybe edit these tighter
edit these better and what can i learn
from videos that are just not holding
people's attention as much and videos
that are losing subscribers or whatever
but the final thing is at the bottom of
the page
here on the channel audit tool it's
going to tell us
how is our title length doing
they recommend that your title should be
between 20 and 60 characters it is best
practices there are times to break that
rule
when
you are really going search based and
maybe packing the end of the title with
some search based language um but
typically short readable punchy titles
under 60 characters are best so it's
letting you know if you're doing well at
that how's your description doing how's
your actionable seo doing are you doing
the best possible
actionable seo now you know what's
interesting is that also when we click
on this one
our videos that have the lowest
actionable seo score are actually videos
that are not
they don't have an seo strategy like
youtube employee reveals the secret to
getting views that's there's nothing seo
about no one's like so what do the
youtube employees think like that
actually is going to show up because of
this a suggested strategy and we teach
both
there's the suggested approach and
there's the search approach but there is
in some cases maybe the ability to go
back this is a huge tip to go back and
re-optimize these now that they've
probably flattened out
and actually go back and
maybe
completely change the title because it's
not going to hurt anything especially if
they have if they're not seo optimized
anyways
so you could go back and actually update
the ch the title to revive the video
into an evergreen search based type of a
title once maybe it's suggested rise has
ended
um and so a ton of insights there but
then ultimately
again uh what practical things should i
fix and update man let me know if you
have any questions specifically about
this tool or specifically about
analytics and um this is the coffee with
kennel show hit like if you're getting
value
that's a good question do shorts always
give low seo yeah shorts don't really
have an seo opportunity to them
now disclaimer they do
when they can be consumed on desktop
and they do to a point if the metadata
helps influence youtube initially to
maybe who it's recommending it to but
shorts are going to be recommended by
the short shelf click-through rate
consumption how wide of appeal do they
have and how much consumption do they
have as they send it to more people
but uh i wouldn't over
optimize or strategize on seo seo would
be heavy-based for
educational content or content that
solves problems right
um in regards to uh
what you're up to now
check out resources in the description
down below we're gonna bring some guests
on for q a uh on coffee with kennel
today answer some questions we've got a
great show ahead but how are you doing
what are you sipping on i got the rise
and grind mug with coffee stains on it
and uh i got my alkaline water let me
know what you're drinking today also if
you haven't heard
um
i just did a free
web class but it's a limited replay
the replay is only available if you
happen to be here on the replay until
november 22nd
so this is november 17th at the time of
going live and recording this
and this video is all about this one
hour class is all about three surefire
video ideas for standing out in a
crowded niche earning passive income and
growing from zero to a hundred thousand
subscribers quick
people were on last night watching this
free class and the feedback was amazing
we went really deep in videos watch this
that are guaranteed to get views i know
that's a big promise
but i guarantee if you
follow what i teach in this class you
will get views on your videos because
the biggest mistake i made early on in
my journey was just making random videos
about the wrong things you could go to
my sean cannell channel back in 2010 for
about five years and i was all over the
place i wasn't titling my videos right
but i really wasn't making
the
practical youtube videos that are
guaranteed to make to get views and 90
of people in our think media community
make this mistake so i want you to check
out this free class
thinkmasterclass.com is the url to um
to
register for the limited replay and it's
just on demand right now but we are
taking it down on monday november
22nd
um okay we got more coffee in the place
i'm gonna i'm about to after today's
coffee with kennel i'll re-up
the coffee for today a lot of coffee
with cannell's show
shout out to the logo up top
shout out to i forgot to do my intro
bumper um drinking tea here finished vra
foundations hey way to go rex
that's amazing and then you can see on
screen right now
think master class dot com
um in terms of the free
uh
uh youtube masterclass and it's all
about three surefire ideas for standing
out in a crowded niche and so definitely
check that out
and um hit the like button if you've
been getting value
and we are about to have ebony on the
show today
uh ebony how's it going and uh
let me know where you're watching from
unmute your mic and i'm gonna pull your
channel out uh channel up what's going
on well i'm excited to be here i'm here
from asheboro north carolina
awesome yeah and uh
what's your question today okay so my
niche
this i hate that question but my niche
is um really digital marketing i like to
do marketing simplified i pivoted the
page from a beauty channel we were make
me over ebb we were makeovers
um
so i pivoted to business or
website makeovers um but this as you can
see is one of my
most popular posts that i wrote during
covid
that just kind of what did you use to
capture this and share your screen oh i
i use zoom
nice okay before i figured out before i
learned about stream yard which i'm on
board with stream yard um
but yeah i use zoom and i did this last
year i was trying to revive my page and
so i thought this is a question that
people ask me a lot and so i just did
this video
did screen record and people are like
commenting and
and so forth and um
did you edit it much or did you just
kind of review it straight or just do it
straight through
i
i shot the edit
i just reviewed a straight through not a
lot of editing
so and then you recorded it and zoom
edited it lightly and then uploaded it
yes
so really quick is just something to um
encourage uh
everybody watching
notice you know ebony got 26 000 views
off of um
using zoom right and we all can have
access to zoom
sharing her screen doing a tutorial
talking about canva by chance have you
signed up to be an affiliate partner for
canva i did yes yes now now the funny
thing is when i um originally did this
video the description did not look like
it did now but when i took your
the um the youtube class and i'm in vra
of course i updated the descriptions and
i noticed like when i made those little
tweaks it just kept rising and rising
that's amazing so that's another cool
insight ebony's bringing the tips today
oh no
she's got the time codes here she's got
an affiliate for canva she just used
zoom minimal editing 26 000 views my
friends you gotta just press record
and obviously there's uh you're
implementing with a lot of strategy and
stuff here too but i want to get to your
question so how can i help today okay so
what with the whole idea of niching and
pivoting right so i originally was a
beauty channel and on my page one of my
top videos was how to tie a head wrap
that's what i i did and talked about
hair makeup but i do websites i make
websites i pivoted to talking more about
that
um what should i do with those old
videos
is it my ego that just wants to keep
them i mean i see you referencing old
videos i have unlisted them because i
know i think you said with the um so it
doesn't come up in search and skew the
channel but what do i do with those
videos just let them go delete them put
them on another channel use them as a
case study well here's the thing is this
how to tie a head wrap is not unlisted
i know i just i just unlisted it just
like maybe a week ago
okay but i can still get to it
no no what i'm saying excuse me i just
made it public away again
sorry
you're like ah the views it's still
doing well i don't want to lose it i'm
like i'm like oh god those views those
views so my question is should i just
let it go
just was it just a moment in time i
should just that was fun back then ebony
you're exactly right this is a challenge
that um
you know when we have some success on
youtube we have a breakout video and let
us know think in the comments
do you have a video on your channel
that's bringing you a lot of views a lot
of subscribers something you made back
in the day and it's not the video that
it's not the topic that you're covering
today the painful thing ebony is to
actually say listen if this is
attracting the wrong people which it is
because it's not where your channel is
going in the future no then it actually
is more harmful than helpful
views are a vanity metric in this point
in this in this sense because someone
sees it they go oh cool how to tie a
head wrap and they click subscribe and
then you upload a video on how to create
instagram posts on canva and they don't
click on it because they wanted more
head wrap they wanted more beauty stuff
and so ultimately everybody watching
this video we need to be we need to make
the painful disciplined decision to say
if there are videos in my library
even if they're making me kind of feel
good with the dopamine hit oh yeah they
get so many views though and they're
actually growing the channel subscribers
it's not actually growing this channel
right and
if once we realize that again
yeah every subscriber
you never want to upload videos that
your subscribers didn't subscribe for
okay
so if they subscribe for the head wrap
you either need to start uploading
beauty videos again which is not where
your futures go no no it's not where i'm
going or you need to
avoid getting the wrong subscribers and
not a lot of people will tell you this
because in generic youtube information
right it's just like as many subscribers
as possible just to get as big as number
as possible and that is not what it
really looks like to have success as a
youtube entrepreneur you want to be a
meaningful specific not a wandering
generality it i'd rather have a thousand
focus subscribers that want to find
custom stock photos and figure out how
to do instagram carousels in canva and
all the stuff that you're doing because
that's going to build up your marketing
influence it's going to build up the
right base of subscribers as opposed to
having a large vanity metric of a
confused audience
okay so just
yeah okay all right there it is there it
is well you answered my question i've
been holding on to it thank you
you're welcome ebony was that helpful
today no it was very helpful and um
i just i have to move on with this phase
of my
life and i believe you're making a smart
move too you're moving into a profitable
niche
like you're moving into a solving a
problem
and and helping a lot of people niche i
believe in terms what's your ambition
ultimately what do you want to happen
well right now i'm working on a course
um
pivoting from services to courses
and so i'm working on a course for like
my
i have one for canva which is what did
did okay and then i'm creating on on
building a website
so
i know
work from home full-time income and
beyond yes yes basically how you can
leave your job kind of like what you're
doing you use youtube to leave your job
you can create a website leave your job
because that's exactly what i did so
ebony like so you've got such a clear
vision put blinders on burn the boats of
everything that has nothing to do with
the vision okay and yeah i mean you want
everything leading towards this course
leading towards the audience that's
interested in in in the website building
and and the affiliate marketing and
you're in such a s you have such a smart
plan now the key is to double down on
the plan and kill any distractions that
don't have anything to do with that plan
okay well thank you that you validated
what i needed to hear
awesome ebony i appreciate you so much
all right thank you
my friends
burn the boats kill distractions
brenda says the right subscribers that's
what it's all about paul you got to do
the right subscribers it's not just
about who can get the most subscribers
i've met a lot of broke influencers um
i've spoken especially
events are back now been at a couple
events but over the years i've speak
spoken at a lot of the social media and
content creator events and
there are many
influencers with big numbers big vanity
numbers at times that maybe had a season
of success but are now they're living
paycheck to paycheck even though
sometimes brands have paid them a lot of
money because they're just
their audiences maybe fickle like they
they had a couple successful videos they
broke out for a moment but one day
they're hot one day they're not
they are now maybe sitting in their
channels kind of collected so many
random subscribers that sure they got a
hundred thousand subs or 250 000 subs or
even a million but their channels kind
of died and they found theirself more in
an irrelevancy because they have such a
confused audience
you flip it to the other side we have
video ranking academy students like jen
devore who has 500 subscribers on
youtube and is doing 10 000 a month why
because it's the right subscribers
because she has a real business plan
because she has a real focus she's
disciplined and watch this
if you
can let go of your ego
if you can actually say
whether i become famous or not i don't
care can we go can we be a little real
today because everyone on social media
we're trying to just flex silver play
buttons and we're trying to just hit
these big numbers like look at and and
more power by the way more power to you
why not get big numbers
but not at the expense of being purpose
driven and staying on brand and on
mission and focused on what you really
need to be doing in terms of building a
high impact and high profit business and
you don't need you need a thousand true
fans not a million subscribers and you'd
be stunned by how many gen x and baby
boomers are are having they got you
don't even know who they are they're not
famous
but they're making six figures
because they're serving a specific
audience they're solving a specific
problem they're making specific content
and they have a specific business model
that's all engineered to really serve
and change lives and also monetize
at a very strategic way and so it's a
really cool conversation i kind of i'm
glad that ebony brought that up in sort
of a nuanced way but i want all of us to
hear this in the thick media podcast
community
especially like north american culture
and maybe it spreads around the globe
we're selling a vanity man you know what
i mean we just so are into like people
buy instagram followers people buy
youtube subscribers that is such
i'm not trying to be mean if you've
bought them
i'm just saying it just doesn't matter
like if that's a vanity number those are
not real subscribers
but that's that's kind of what culture
we just want to flex as opposed to have
real impact
if you have a 100 true fans and you
really impact and change their lives
like you could build a full-time income
as a creator
and and if you can let go
of oh i just want the big numbers i just
want to be seen i want the if you can
just let that stuff go
man you have a lot more peace and it'll
give you a lot more calm
in terms of
building brick by brick to to say what
does success really look like
does success really look like my
subscriber account number or my bank
account number
success really look like
a silver play button or does success
really look like engineering my youtube
channel so i can work 20 hours a week
spend time with my family and make
as much as i was at my corporate job
like what does success really look like
okay rant over we're gonna have daniel
on here next um and uh smash like if
you're getting value out of coffee with
kennel today daniel how's it going and
uh let me know where you're watching
from love the christmas tree already up
we got ours up as well but it's not
decorated yet uh we just have the lights
on but uh where are you watching from
and tell me a little bit about your
channel
yeah so i am from uh apache junction
really is where i'm living but uh it's
the suburb of phoenix arizona
and so um
yeah my wife loves the christmas trees
uh to decorate early so that's that's
her thing um
but uh we're just uh just started our
channel about six months ago
and so
um my question is just kind of
um
we're going we're pivoting towards the
full-time rv living
and so we want to
um we've been doing more of like
campsite reviews and
um
things of that nature so just kind of
um didn't know how
i should proceed like right now we don't
uh also we want to um i guess i would
say
we want to um help people in
everybody that's bought rvs we just went
when you saw i just went to nascar the
guys next to us didn't know anything
about travel trailers or how to level
them and stuff like that um
so
um and then yeah so
i love it man well hey thank you so much
for being on coffee with candle today i
actually want to start by just talking
about optimizing the home page of your
channel um this is a
i think a big opportunity
to for a lot of us that we just kind of
miss and it's the idea of here's the
question i want everyone here to ask
what is your home page
experience on your youtube channel now
if you only posted one or two videos
don't worry about this
but there's a couple sections that are
pretty important first of all is
essentially going to be your channel
trailer or your um what videos that
people that are already subscribed see
if if they're unsubscribed they will see
either a channel trailer or don't worry
about making a channel trailer
just make your most popular video or the
best introduction to you or the video
most likely to convert subscribers
as your
channel trailer then it'll say youtube
will say what video
do you want to be for returning
subscribers and then you also can select
that then furthermore you can select
playlists
and categories like
uploads to be the top thing after the
trailer or the return video
other channels to subscribe to in our
case we want to grow our podcast channel
and then playlists that are hopefully
under thematic topics that you want to
drive traffic to
in our case how to actually create
a youtube channel make your first video
we have that all in a playlist cameras
for dummies and other categories and
don't overthink this until you have
as many videos as think media you're
probably not going to have all of these
different categories but now let's
review your channel the first thing i
don't like is that shorts is first
shorts could be on here but shorts is
also a mobile experience and i would
actually move it down
furthermore when i look at shorts
they're the worst first impression
because happy memorial day weekend is
meaningless to me channel update i don't
know you yet is meaningless to me and we
are on a mission is meaningless to me
yeah so when i landed on the channel i
actually initially when i got here
thought you only had three videos
saw these and was like oh man and then i
was like oh wait a minute you actually
got some like great uploads that are
more and those are actually pushed down
by shorts so your action items would be
um
pick a channel trailer or make one or
just pick your best performing video
that would introduce people to your
channel
and then potentially consider
what are the categories
of your videos and everybody watching
this can do the same right
what are the bigger buckets of types of
videos that you're going to do are you
going to do rv questions are you going
to do
tours of campsites or campsite reviews
and rather than just titling your
playlists camping or nascar title them
like a real value based title gopro tips
and tricks video series how to start and
grow a podcast in 2021 that playlist
title is a real idea it's a real cl
clear search based phrase and then over
time we can stack up videos on how to
create cover art
how to start the podcast how to start
for beginners using just a phone using
different equipment how to choose the
right name and so
uh this kind of helps you strategize the
content buckets i view playlists as like
content buckets and i actually don't
want to overemphasize
playlists like being a game changer for
your channel the key is playlists are
the way
you organize your homepage so so the
playlists that you're organizing help me
know
where are you taking me daniel
like what can i learn from you can i oh
campsite reviews great i could i could
check out some campsite reviews oh
tips about buying an rv awesome i could
watch that series
and and
even more importantly is rather than you
just coming up in your own mind with
what types of buckets you should be i
would be creating
clusters and categories of videos
that the biggest number of people are
interested in especially early on when
you want to grow
your channel does that make sense daniel
yeah definitely that helps a lot so yeah
and i love canva so like i've been using
canva a lot too is like as many as well
so um and just going through the vra
program as well so that's very helpful
how far are you in vra so far daniel um
i just went through the
second module so
awesome
yeah getting definitely getting great
value out of it
awesome man well i appreciate you and
then you know the final thing is
uh one of the coolest and most practical
ways we can all grow our channel
is the strategy we call a s q answer
specific
questions and
you are taught your top two performing
videos fall into that category how
towing capacity is determined now that's
actually i love that question because
it's so specific it's such a unique
thing and i think what we'll end up
seeing is that this video will actually
continue to get views because it's it's
it's not just like how to pick an rv a
lot of people would have that right or
just like really it's it's very nuanced
and and then
um how to tent camp for free and so
when building up the foundation of your
channel
i think the two big tips on these for
maybe improving them would be one what
are the best questions i should
answer and then two would be
stay tuned we're gonna be talking about
payload capacity and towing
what i would do is let me actually turn
the audio on here
do you want to know what your truck can
pull
stay tuned so
i'll give you one quick tip and it just
summarizes like the entire tip i would
say is answer specific questions but
also then make the answer
as short as punchy
and as effective as possible
what you're going to probably do most in
editing and so
uh six minutes is a great video here
this video will perform in all of our
videos for everybody watching will
perform better
the quicker we get to the point and so
the first thing i notice
is
one i'm glad you did edit because i
could see all these edits two don't be
afraid to trim a little bit of the down
moments especially in the hook time and
so watch this do you want to know what
your truck can pull
because that was great first two seconds
do you want to know what your truck can
pull
stay tuned that breath right there was
an entire second like we could have just
went
do you want to know what your truck can
pull
stay tuned notice that like so you take
the breath and that so that's just an
opportunity for a jump cut you don't
have to jump cut like crazy like a
youtuber where it's so fast that it
causes people to but like
like as much as you could trim this down
so as you're answering specific
questions the video seven minutes if it
could be sick a six i would like it
better if it could be five minutes and
30 seconds i'd like it better you don't
have to overly make it crazy to get it
there but try to trim as much fluff as
possible and so as you're growing your
channel as you hear in vra all the time
right get one percent better with every
upload think about
um you know what can i actually remove
that's one of the best questions
what can actually go to the cutting room
floor and i'll tell you a quick story to
end you know i'm blessed today obviously
i edited my own videos for over 10 years
built the channel up by myself i'm sure
like you're doing with your family and
and what how most of us are doing but
today you know we have editors on the
team and one of our editors is kyle
anderson and so
i still
daniel getting on camera have the
propensity to uh
want to share a lot want to teach all
the details and want to whatever you
know
and so i did this video all about
the audio setup at uh
at my other office about how i set up
all the audio and
i i sat down i was being as concise as
possible and i recorded this video and
it all went into the premiere pro
timeline and then kyle said hey sean
let's get on zoom and he goes bro this
entire middle part
isn't completely unnecessary like i feel
it was 13 minutes he goes
he goes honestly i think i can cut out
like this is this is not helping the
story this is fluff and it was literally
in a 13-minute video it was like minute
four to minute eleven
and and then he's telling me and i go
yeah but i don't know i really think
people need to know this
and so kyle called in the reinforcements
and he called in tony and tony got on
zoom and he was like
yeah bro no i think that this you don't
need this like this six minutes like
this could be shorter and it's
people aren't even gonna know it's gone
sean and i'm like but but i want to
share my voice you know but like but
there's so much stuff people need to
know well
of course
uh tony and kyle outnumbered me
um and and they were like we should cut
it and i go okay well i trust you we cut
it out and and the average iteration is
better the video is stronger because it
wasn't 13 minutes because it was seven
you know and
and nobody knew it was gone of course
because how would they ever have known
in the first place and so
i think a macro encouragement for you is
first you're doing amazing i mean you
already got you got 200 videos on this
view uh this this top viewed video here
you're producing content but just to
encourage you as you continue to go
through vora and in general just keep
getting one percent better with every
upload and and do your best to
detach yourself from your content
put the viewer first and think about how
can i make this half short and twice
strong what can i cut out because as you
increase your average view duration as
you increase people comp your average
percentage view to people completing the
video that's going to stack on top of a
good title and a good thumbnail and how
you're going to get more breakout videos
i'm sure you're like me if we go look
for how to like set up a smoker or
barbecue or how to you know set up our
rv or whatever and we see the top ranked
videos on youtube and we think we can
get the answer on the 11 minute video
instead of the 33 minute video i'm
probably gonna start with the 11 minute
video because if it answers my question
i would much rather get to that answer
in one third of the time does that make
sense yes definitely
my man
i appreciate you thanks so much for
coming on coffee with kennel today yes
thank you
all right hey merry christmas and take
care
oh daniel uh thanks so much for coming
on smash like if you're getting value my
friends can i ask you a hard question
can you
make your video stronger
do you think if you were really honest
that there's some stuff you could cut
out of your videos tell me in the
comments do you think that you're like
me and sometimes there's a lot you want
to say there's it's because you care
about the viewer it's because you want
to share information it's because you
want to educate
but do you think it's because you're
vlogging and because you did so many
cool things at disney world but honestly
friend especially when you're starting
you're a six minute vlog
with the hot highlights and the best
moments and the funniest moments it's
gonna be a lot more powerful than a
40-minute vlog of your entire day
at disney world walking around right and
so matthew's saying yep mr cast iron
saying yep
lost again and saying yep jim good to
see you i mean i just think that uh we
can
um all agree
that uh
we could make our videos a little bit
stronger and and here's the thing this
is it to be overwhelming
it's not
to
to slow down so much on your next video
that you over analyze it and overthink
it
it's about getting one percent better
on your next video tighten it up a
little bit more
on your next video
jump cut the one second out of the hook
where you took the breath because
what makes youtube videos
powerful
is editing
because none of us are that good i just
paused for three seconds trying to think
about what i was gonna say next
in editing that three seconds is gone
right and the viewer is getting to the
point quicker
so as we get one percent better to be
more specific i'm talking about
as you're editing your
videos take a little bit more time at it
get a little bit faster at editing
trim the fluff
be like kyle and tony and cut five
minutes out of sean's 13-minute video
seven minutes out of sean's 13-minute
video
which also encourages you to
get feedback
get get objective feedback maybe you
have a family member a friend that can
come over sit him in front of your
youtube video here's the test sit him
down
be like hey
hey you know ernie can you watch this
video
and
and if you could be in person with them
watch this this is
first if they will give you honest
feedback they might just tell you that's
pretty good and then maybe ask them do
you think i could cut any of it out
they're like yeah i think this part was
unnecessary because you might be too
close to the problem i am you might be
too close to the video and two
emotionally involved that you need some
outside feedback but here's the test
you say hey ernie watch this video he's
watching he's watching
you kind of back away you're sitting
over his shoulder it's like creating a
little focus group with a friend you're
playing the laptop in front of him
he's watching the video
if he's watching your six minute video
and ernie does this
you know you lost him if you lose ernie
to the second screen
then you know that your editing could be
a little bit snappier right or that your
storytelling could be a little bit
snappier i don't want this to feel
overwhelming
making
attention holding and retaining youtube
videos is an art form it's a moving
target attention spans are fickle
but this is the kind of stuff that's
really going to help you get more views
and grow your channel is making your
content half short and twice strong it's
thinking about those moments where maybe
your energy dropped or thinking about
those moments where maybe it was
unnecessary or thinking about those
moments where ernie's attention was
locked in the whole time but then things
kind of went sideways in the edit so he
was like huh i wonder
start swiping on tinder right like ernie
is distracted on tinder now and because
there was a moment in the video that
broke his attention and the one percent
better refining of
you on camera communicating how you're
structuring your content but friend
fix and post
it's editing where all the sudden wow
sean really got his point across in a
concise way there that's a really great
five minute video little did you know
that the reason it was a great five
minute video is because seven minutes
was cut out
and sean looks a lot better on the other
side
of that video editing
my friends i hope you're getting values
coffee with kennel today smash like we
got nick and jewel on in just a bit and
uh fired up for that
saucer said it's always ernie man uncle
ernie you know i'm excited to see him at
thanksgiving
and uh man he always gets a little crazy
uh what actually is the uncle i always
think about the uncle in
national lampoon's christmas
uh
is his name ernie let me know who that
uncle is
i need the moose you know the eggnog
moose from national lampoon so you know
the scene is anybody with me uh where
they got the
fanned out moose
clear glass you know uh eggnog glasses
um and so uh i appreciate you nora
thanks for being here and uh i'm glad
you're getting value cousin eddie
coleman thank you we're switching it
it's cousin eddie now you know cousin
eddie's gonna be at thanksgiving
give cousin eddie some eggnog and sit
him down in front of your video and say
hey hey eddie what do you think can and
if you can hold eddie's attention
because eddie's a little buzzed
and he doesn't even care about your
channel if you can edit your videos in
such a way as to hold cousin eddie's
attention then uh then you know you're
on to something uh eileen thank you so
much for the super chat today really
appreciate you and grateful that you're
getting value out of the think media
podcast
um with heather taurus hey as we get
ready for our next guest that reminds me
that if you're not subscribed to the
think media podcast today is the day to
do so now of course
you are um
here on the think media podcast channel
watching coffee with kennel or listening
right now so if you haven't pressed the
subscribe button and turn on
notification on notifications on this
channel now's the time to do so but
maybe you want to take think media
the think media podcast with you and
your
bluetooth headphones while you are
running errands while you're taking a
walk whatever then
know that the think media podcast is on
all audio platforms so if you want to
jump on apple podcasts
and um you could you could get it there
if you want to jump on spotify it's
there it's all over all the google and
uh
audible
pirate radio stitcher
all those different platforms but
wherever you listen to podcasts
definitely
subscribe to the think media podcast and
check out the audio version if you like
that and
eileen i really appreciate the super
chat if anybody loves the thick media
podcast it would mean the world to me if
you left us a review on apple podcast
apple podcast is pretty much the only
place where we can um
get reviews uh in an effective way and
so if the podcast has impacted your life
consider sharing it and i would love it
if you left
a review that would mean the world to
me heather heather and i
proper english uh we got a ques a
question from b
a z fit that i'll answer in just a
second but we got nick coming up so nick
welcome to the show where are you
watching from and tell me a little bit
about your channel
i am watching from murfreesboro
tennessee um i started a kind of a
backpacking channel
or maybe three four years ago and my
son's uh
youtube channel for legos
um
so
there's a lot of
i find a lot of interesting things about
backpacking i've been doing it for a lot
of years i got to travel to everest in
2012.
nice to the summit
i actually did go to the summit i won
the trip through rei
adventures so we went to advanced base
camp um
had a great time there um
but
you know
i've had a lot of time here recently i
was just hit by a car hit and run on my
one wheel
back oh no yeah back in september so
fractured my skull
had a brain head wearing a helmet
uh actually i wasn't i just i normally
do but i wasn't and i was on a sidewalk
so the car came up on the sidewalk no
way yeah and so you drunk driver
we don't know i mean that they they
can't hold the hit and run it right he
came up on the sidewalk yeah bro i'm so
sorry that's all right um so i've had a
lot of time to sit and
get some things together and i joined
bra last night
oh welcome to the fam yeah i appreciate
it so
i'm ready to grow this and figure out
what i need to do to get it going
amazing well uh nick
first of all glad you're okay and uh
appreciate it and second thanks thanks
for jumping into vra
the first thing um
i'm actually gonna point you to is as
you know you joined last night and we
are doing a special offer right now
where um you get the youtube starter kit
just included in there yeah so if you
want i would say first thing to do is
open that up and jump into the um the
thumbnail section because
the immediate
place i want to see you go next
is with graphic design
okay um
i'm going to be bold because i want you
to get results and i want you to win
the avatar is is terrible like it's it's
it's just it's
if we break it down you know
there's you you're look at look at
little you you're little you the green
jacket is barely in the corner there i
see there's a bible verse love that but
like
it's the avatar should be
a clear
um
vivid
uh
probably picture of you this is a good
channel so you can definitely see she's
back you know nice lighting nice sun so
if that's all it is that's a selfie you
could do it that way this is obviously a
little bit more
of a crispy kind of photo so you don't
have to take it to that level yeah and
then i also like this this is also what
i'm thinking about it's a clear logo
based
um avatar that's up to you and you know
what's interesting is as you go into the
youtube starter kit you're gonna see
that you can use things like canva.com
which we highly recommend
and say like uh
i'm just jumping on canva to see what is
here
is like watch how fast you could do this
like you could just jump on here i typed
in hiking logo
and you could say okay
um which one of these do i kind of like
and you could take
you know
this and just type in your text
you know and so don't overthink it you
don't need to hire a logo design company
we're living in an era where you can
very quickly level up your graphic
design and then secondly is is that
thumbnail side is um
you could
pull
a lot of
like
minimally
you know even though you're like well
i'm not this this girl you you get a
nice photo and you just have you use the
text in this white text
the white boxes and the black text as
hiking essentials and then you throw a
picture a selfie of you behind there or
whatever so because the immediate
experience that i get is wanting to just
see the level up of your
i like the name of the channel
uh i like i level up of your avatar and
then in
improving of the thumbnails themselves
so then this the second kind of skill
set is just
um
beyond
using canva to just start leveling up
thumbnails
is also getting a little bit more into
photography what camera are you using to
use a gopro actually uh when i first
started uh iphone then the gopro and a
canon m50 which i got the idea from
watching uh think media channel
so what what gopro do you have uh well i
no longer have one i had the nine so
i sold it and i've got an a7 3 now oh
okay great
um
and then what iphone do you have
the 13 mini
so you know you do have a little bit
when you do the selfie you can make it
wide or you can use the other side and
uh
and so these are really great
uh cameras to just double down a little
bit like
like what i would do is i would go
iphone 13
like photography
and
uh
maybe look for
a video that breaks
breaks down some tips
and so maybe someone like this and tony
this is another one we should have omar
do
and so
this iphone 13 probably max
but if if we go through because i would
tell you my favorite i use the vivid
filter i snap my photos i use the vivid
filter and you can actually see yeah
someone here let's see so he's comparing
two different cameras
i go in and and it's so fast like just
no i don't have any apps i don't have
any custom you know whatever uh and so
what i'm looking for
is when you are out hiking when you're
snapping photos on your phone i'm
looking for the contrast
and the and the saturation and the
colors
to pop more
um so that i mean as you can see when
you even think about just these
thumbnails like how this iphone
thumbnail looks you know all these top
videos they have a lot of color pop to
them and when i look at
at some of these especially i know we're
going back now a year and we're in a
whole new era here but like there was a
huge this got 8 000 views on your iphone
12
osmo 4 video and i and i can't even
imagine probably would have got 50 000
views or 150 if it had
a thumbnail that wasn't mostly wood
table and like that didn't really you
know what i mean and so if you go
dji
and and everybody watching this you can
pull off
thumbnails like this and
and thumbnails like this using canva or
thumbnails like this shooting on a
smartphone now i recognize you would
maybe need two phones because obviously
a phone is in the picture there and
maybe someone but that's that's the
biggest thing what do you think as far
as kind of tip one nick about leveling
up your photography your thumbnails and
really the graphic design
yeah i i i totally agree with you there
uh looking back now uh i see that so um
like i said you know those were kind of
getting started and i
kind of started building my little
studio up right here so
i think i'm on the right track and
so
i love it and then you also have the a7
iii so that thing's a
beast and we have a whole series on
think media on that okay great i mean
the this the last thing i'd say is like
you know on the one hand
you already have 64
300 views on the channel and you're
already comfortable going out creating
content how i mean are you gonna be back
at hiking right now is your health well
i have actually been uh we took a trip
to the smokies uh a few weeks ago but as
far as getting out and carrying a
backpack i don't know yet um hoping to
go back to work sometime in december
uh just been doing some physical therapy
so
and uh
learning more about my camera and stuff
so i've got some good lenses with it so
hoping to you know get going here
shortly
great so the replay of this video will
be here on the think media channel
because i'll hit you at the rapid fire
of exactly what i'll do next if i'm you
um but what i would do now especially
while you're maybe not even out hiking
is
i would do what we talked about
yesterday i would
asq answer specific questions and i
would rsp review specific products
i'd make some videos because in your
garage you probably have a hiking
backpack and maybe you have
i don't know carabiners i'm just making
stuff up you might have like water
bottles or just different cool
accessories that you hike with is that
true oh i have got ton a closet full of
it yeah so so the key is i need you to
dig deep into vra
because
you'll do decent by just reviewing
specific products but the real nuances
come if you make a video that's like
best
you know
uh i think about like a camel pack or
like best hydration like niche things
and that's what the specific word means
review specific products it could be
versus videos where you compare two
things that you're like i don't like
this one but i love this one and they're
two popular you know hiking belts it
could be
um a category of products that is like
hydration
uh you know best hydration accessories
but i'm not saying that's a good idea
i'm saying the key is following the vra
system to really identify the biggest
impact ideas but while you're you know
recovering
reviewing specific products tapping into
the closet full of stuff and then
answering specific questions that people
could do in terms of preparing for a
hike planning a hike there's stuff they
could do you could do researching hikes
online i don't know if you've got five
tips for how you use google earth how
you
research yelp photos and then you know
or whatever how do you plan a trip
what do you do as far as mapping things
out
really just focus on those two
strategies though answer specific
questions review specific products
you've got your your your thing at home
and your studio you're building it out
and you don't even need a studio but i
mean your gear at home to do it in your
driveway do it you know where you are
right there in front of the window
talk through this stuff um and and just
start posting videos at whatever pace
you feel comfortable with i really think
on the other side of leveling up
your graphics over the next couple
months and even if you can't get out
back out hiking
answering some specific questions
tapping into some of your past b-roll
and your tap pass photography and then
reviewing specific products can get you
a lot of momentum and then you know
we'll also just be
praying you know that
you'll be full strength in the next
three six months and you'll already have
some momentum going on youtube as well
as you know a lot of nuances that you've
learned in vra and then it'll just be
building forward from there what do you
think about that strategy i think that's
a great strategy
i appreciate you nick uh thanks so much
for coming on today hey i appreciate it
thank you for having me i'm sean
my friends smash the like button and the
uh if you're getting value so far we got
tips coming in from the community it's
always good to see you coleman and
recently chris was sharing you know on
our
uh on our staff meetings we share wins
and he was talking about some milestones
that you've hit and just talking about
your channel i'm just so grateful for
you and that you're a part of our
community and a part of era
and so cooking trail food
and trying out pre-made food yep super
interesting like that's i mean
i don't know if it's bougie to say i
shop at whole foods but whole foods does
have all kinds of
they got the things for runners they got
the the little gels for runners they got
the gels with caffeine they got the bee
honey ones they got the other ones you
know you could hit up wherever you shop
or you shop online to get trail mix bars
like that's that's such a good idea like
the latest flavors because people are
wondering like how good is the latest
cliff bars versus the whatever versus
the whatever
and that's something we've learned
recently on fake media not just versus
videos but combining three comparing
three products
it's like
combining
zv1 versus e10 versus a 6400 we've seen
some nuance where people like to
juxtapost three different things so
that's a really good tip coleman if you
um
want to learn i was mentioning the class
that we did uh yesterday
that um
nick was a part of we do have the
limited replay for that up and you can
see on the screen thinkmasterclass.com
that's uh three surefire video ideas for
standing out in a crowded niche i shared
two of them with you it's asq and rsp
but not only do we we go into another
one we talk about 13 different ways to
monetize your videos and again that
class is for free and then at the end of
it uh
we will tell you a little bit more about
video ranking academy if you have any
questions about that or want to learn
nick just joined it yesterday but we
actually are doing i know if you watch
people online and like hype and it's
scarcity and things are ending like
that's not us you might get that vibe
but like
we are doing a special right now it's
our year-end sale that ends monday night
so it's the web class is up
4
until monday night midnight
and then there's three extra bonuses
that we don't normally include with our
entire video racket academy offers so if
you've thought about video raking
academy if you've been on the fence if
you also just want to watch the free
hour-long class
now is definitely the time to check all
of that out just go to
thinkmasterclass.com
and you can watch the on-demand replay
it'll be worth your time and you also
learn about some of the ways we help
people at a deeper level and how you can
be a part of our deepest community here
which is called video ranking
academy
coleman says i'd love to cook for you
and your team someday
approved i mean we're
bro like
let me know when and where i'm down for
some brisket
uh some ribs
can can i put my order in
some grilled salmon
some grilled vegetables um grilled
chicken
uh
that's it that's all that i'm requesting
and some and some steaks
and some some t-bone steaks
so i just need those five forms of meat
and then we'll see what tony and daisy's
order is as well because that was just
for me um
but uh seriously bro that would be
really really fun okay we got jewel
brooks coming up
and uh smash like if you're having fun
on coffee with cannell today
and um
jewel
how's it going
what's your question and where are you
from and tell me a little bit about your
channel
okay so
um well i'm now in georgia but i
moved from wisconsin a month and a half
ago
awesome um
how's youtube going
youtube i'm very scattered
um
i really like travel i really like
making
funny content
and so there's like challenges on there
there's like
um life stuff there's
um
travel videos
um like this video it was just how many
times i skied and like the different
types of hills
that um the ski hill has and like so i
counted each like how many easy ones i
did and how many extreme ones i did and
that kind of thing what camera are you
shooting on here um this is a g7x mark
iii
nice and
um
that's great and so what's your question
so i'm trying to figure out how to like
niche down a little bit because i am a
little bit all over the place which i
think is why i'm not growing as much as
i could be
um
but
like i have all these ideas and i think
that's part of my anagram seven which is
like i can't stick to something
um
but like i have ideas about like right
now we actually haven't had been able to
find a place to live and so we've been
staying in airbnbs and so
i've been taking footage of every airbnb
we've been staying at and thinking about
like
making a video about five different
airbnbs to stay at in atlanta
and
um thinking about like
a series that i'd really love to do is
like getting a map of georgia and
throwing a dart at it every weekend and
then we just go there and
we i have to like
try a food there or learn something
historically about it or and kind of
vlog that
um
but yeah i'm not really sure
yeah let me ask you
what um
if you don't mind me asking what season
of life are you in are you in school are
you working how old are you um well so
i'm 25.
um i'm not in school i'm actually very
weird but
um the reason why i moved to georgia is
because i felt like god was asking me to
be in the entertainment industry okay um
so
i am actually the edutainment industry
no entertainment oh entertainment
industry in georgia yes yes so atlanta
is like um the new hollywood of the
south okay so um i'm doing background
work in movies and stuff
yeah
but i'm doing youtube because it's fun
and it's a creative outlet for me
um
and it has always just been fun to kind
of share my journey and like people get
to watch and see
yes um
but i'm hoping that i can make it so i'm
actually making money off of it
and so what is your ideal vision are you
trying to have like two things in play
like maybe my youtube channel does well
and blows up and i can make money off it
or maybe i want to start earning a
living as an actress
i would say like trying to do both
um
so that uh
um an actress is the goal
the actress is the goal
but
meaning actress in movies like or tv or
or any form
or or commercials but like any jobs i
can get
yep yep
um but youtube is a really great way
because with movies
like i don't have the creative controls
and with youtube i do
and so that's why i
i mean i started youtube
three years ago i think before the
acting even kind of became a thing
and
so
using that as a creative outlet
and
i'm hoping that
through youtube i would be able to fund
myself so that i wouldn't have to have a
third job as i'm trying to build up my
acting career as well do you have a
third job right now
not at the moment but you'll need to get
one
probably
yeah
because you'll go acting career youtube
third job on the hustle until one of
those things
completely pays the bills or whatever
right yeah yeah
okay cool so
i mean it's a great conversation i
really appreciate you coming on and um
i think
that
you have options we all do it's youtube
meaning it's your tube you can take it
whatever direction you want on the one
hand i think that you're actually doing
this it sounds contrary to what maybe
people hear from me most of the time but
i think you're actually doing the
absolute right thing
you said a key phrase you said this is a
creative outlet to me this is a place of
experimentation to me this is a place of
creativity to me this is a place of
having fun
it's also a place where you are building
your personal brand and so anytime we
name our youtube channel after our first
and our last name
and we're building up our personal brand
as you i'm sure know that in the
entertainment industry
um
the better and stronger your personal
brand with examples or content or
subscribers or instagram followers
the bigger your platform the more
influence you have in traditional um and
sometimes the more doors will open up
for auditions and stuff potentially
so
if you can grow your personal bra brand
around you being funny you being
creative you're doing some skits
sometimes you're doing different things
then that could be
the quote unquote strategy
you keep doing the creative outlet
hopefully um things continue to grow and
maybe you get more known as an
entertainer meaning you would just be
kind of deciding that
i am
looking to be
followed
as
an entertainer
um
on youtube
and to the degree we have clarity like
that then our question can really be to
double down on saying all right so let
me
let me experiment with other content
formats and keep going and for some of
those watching this i want you to hear
this too again we say niche down or find
a niche but sometimes
we learn by just creating
and you can't steer a parked car so
you're doing a great job you've been
posting for three years you can steer
this wherever you want it to go
um but potentially you kind of just lean
into that
it i know it feels random and it is but
it's also you and a lot of us we have a
lot of you know different personalities
and whatever and if we talked about
everything we want to talk about you
know if i talked about everything i want
to talk about on youtube
uh
one day i'd be talking about doing a
bible study uh the next day i would talk
about kettlebells the next day i talk
about all my supplements that i'm taking
the next day i would talk about
leadership and then the next day i would
talk about a camera so i would be all
over the place and
that would be what it is on my sean
cannell channel
but does that make sense on the one hand
i guess i'm saying
i think you're you're really moving
forward and it's going pretty well what
do you think about that
that is not what i thought you were
gonna say so okay
um
yeah but then i'm going to say what i'm
going to say second and that is
but if
you if you want to
monetize youtube as soon as soon as
possible
you might need a different approach
gotcha so
and i like that you're a person of faith
so if you're stepping out in faith
you're leaning in and you're 25 you're
super young you should just be taking
risks as you are
experimenting as you are
leaning in you know i guess it also is a
budget of how much time are you devoting
to entertainment industry hollywood
stuff new hollywood of the south and how
much time are you devoting to youtube
i would say well right now we're mostly
doing
um
acting stuff and i'm like trying to
however
well it changes every i would say
well
average since being here
probably
two to three days of 12 to 15 hour days
yep so
and then and then
a little bit of recovery and then
youtube the rest of the time yeah
okay and then on youtube you just work
eight hour days or whatever i mean and
you said we who's we oh i
i i usually
i talk about god as a we kind of
because we're doing this together
because i wouldn't be doing this without
him um so
no i love it so okay so two to three
days 12 to 15 hours a day uh and then
and then youtube the rest of the week
another two to three days do you hustle
that hard on youtube
um i want to get back into that um i
have filmed a bunch of stuff but i have
the editing part that i need to sit down
and do
so you could work two to three days i
mean and you might definitely need you
got that day of rest in there and maybe
a recovery day but you could probably
work at least two days eight hours a day
on youtube right yeah so so now the
question becomes okay
this is a
ultimately what we're talking where a
lot of us friends
of course we talk about youtube strategy
titles videos but one of the whole other
conversation that heather taurus on our
team really focuses on is like
yeah but how much time do you have what
are your priorities what's on your
calendar how are you budgeting your time
and so
if we're going to make a plan jewel this
is the thing for you to think about
again
you can keep
youtube being entertainment and i'm i'm
i'm really okay with that because this
is your tube you're you could do what
you want
but i lean more on the very practical
and i asked myself a couple questions i
asked myself like what is
the shortest path to revenue
and and in this case the shortest path
to revenue might be getting a job that
being a waitress thing that gets tips
that might be the third job that you
need so at some point that's how you
answer the question is like i need to
get a job i'm going to start driving
uber and
earn money so at least i cover
bills or whatever but then also it's
like what's the shortest path
online you would say or online or on
youtube
the next question i would think is that
if i'm going to be a youtube
entrepreneur
which
it doesn't mean you're not an
entrepreneur but if you're a entertainer
it is kind of a different approach
if you're a youtube entrepreneur
and scratch the word youtube if you're
just an entrepreneur entrepreneurs solve
problems for a profit
so you have to ask yourself what problem
does your channel solve
now even entertainers have to solve a
problem comedians solve the problem of
people need escape they need humor they
need to relax they need to de-stress
they want to laugh
people are looking for escape they're
looking for
entertainment they're looking for
something to watch they're looking for a
connection they're looking for an
influencer to follow they're locked down
they're looking for entertaining content
that might be the problem you solve but
entrepreneurs really solve problems like
people have chronic pain they talk about
how to deal with chronic pain
people are trying to balance their taxes
they they um you know
they watch your turbo tax tutorials
watch this
i don't know if you have this
credibility yet but
actors are looking for how to get
auditions there could be a channel that
actually is business based
that and i'm sure there actually is that
helps people
how do you uh get more auditions
what is the best way to get the whatever
professional headshots and where should
you get them and how to save money on
them how to create your own professional
headshots without even whatever this
might not even be a skill set of yours
but that would be the more entrepreneur
side think about it when you tap into
solving a problem you you open up the
possibility of you could start saying
are you going to create an online course
you don't have to am i going to do
affiliate marketing so what does
affiliate marketing do well affiliate
marketing if i connected to solving a
problem would be
um
i help people with chronic pain
and therefore
i
have uh therapy and recovery physical
therapy devices i could talk about those
earn money with affiliate marketing i
could talk about supplements and um
different
role on mental you know pain solves i
can talk about that on affiliate
marketing um
i help people get out of debt i could
talk about or with personal finance i
could talk about credit cards as an
affiliate so
when we open up
what is the shortest path to revenue
in my opinion the shortest path to
revenue is having what essentially i'd
be calling a clear business model which
means where you niche down
is related to
something that
is a clear business model
in that direction of things um
and to be clear the influencer aka
entertainer aka
youtube creator business model
is going to be
views
eventually brands maybe it's brands that
want to reach your gen z audience
um want to advertise in your videos
it's gonna be adsense ad revenue
and uh that's probably it the big one to
punch
not even really affiliate marketing it's
larger viewership you're making adsense
and it's larger viewership you're
getting eventually brands uh want to
work with you like you did a tick tock
four course mule challenge
eventually this gets enough views and
dairy queen legit wants to sponsor an
entertaining series with you so like
that's of course how the influencer game
works
so to me
jewel let me know if you have questions
about these two paths and let me know
which one do you like best and if
anything shows up path number one
is you keep being jewel brooks the
personal brand you try to be as funny as
possible keep being creative and i want
you to be encouraged like you've been
doing this three years
things are you've accomplished a lot you
have 55 000 views
some of your videos your most viewed
video has 14 000 views so if you double
down on com three years old right but
like a year ago you got 5000 views when
you're cutting your brother's hair so if
you say like
okay if i'm gonna double down on this
kind of entertaining content for a
particular audience
that's where i'd like to go i would like
to go that direction and then i don't
know if it's you'd want to be in like
disney channel stuff but if
cutting my brother's hair the style of
those thumbnails kind of makes me think
of like nickelodeon disney or just makes
me think of that so so you start getting
clear of saying i want to stack all my
energies into at least going this way
now i'm not sure if it can work or not i
don't know if any of the ways are going
to work but i want to like stack
everything because the more i'm on tick
tock and youtube maybe doing youtube
shorts the more i'm funny the more i can
show myself as an actress and the more i
double down on what i'm doing in the
entertainment industry i'm gonna go that
direction
to me that i i feel that's what you've
already been doing and where your
strength is but path number two that was
path number one path number two would be
um i'm really gonna lean into a
particular passion
or particular niche
that
i feel
i have a skill in and that i could
monetize and i'm gonna kind of build a
business around that
even if it's
different there's nothing wrong
with having a side business
in a way it'd almost be like
i'm gonna do essential oils i'm gonna
sign up for young living
now we're in direct selling but like i'm
gonna sign up for young living i'm gonna
do essential oils i'm gonna talk all
about health and essential oils and i'm
gonna build up a channel and i'm just
gonna try to get that to three four five
k a month boom business model there it
is
build it up over 12 24 36 months and you
have a 5k a month
business and direct selling and youtube
and multiple income streams and that's
not even your biggest passion but now
you're over here and you've built
an engine that's super clear to fund
your whole entertainment aspiration or
maybe the two things blend together so
as we land the plane joule how do you
feel about path number one versus path
number
two well
i feel like path number two would almost
have to be like a whole nother thing
where i would have to like refocus
almost and i almost feel like i would
have to make a whole nother channel
versus path number one
i
go into what i'm already doing and just
get more creative and get more
going in that direction
um
but i see like the benefits to both
for sure
i love it and i and i would agree with
you and i wanted to have this whole
conversation for
those listening but in the limited time
we've gotten to kind of know each other
i i would also go path number one and by
the way there's something powerful about
making a decision think media there's
something powerful about saying
i've thought about where i'm gonna go
this is where i'm gonna go i don't know
all the details but i'm gonna lean in
and be decisive so here's your next
steps jewel again i think it all aligns
youtube is your creative outlet your
goal is to be followed your goal is to
be an entertainer and then your goal is
to double down in the entertainment
industry
then i would go all in
and i would then study
those
that are succeeding in that area to be
honest right this is going to be a
little bit less of of the examples we
talk about the most at think media
because we talk about
like everybody who uh
not everybody but a lot of people in our
community are talking about they're
doing cooking channels or they're doing
kids occupational therapy or they're
doing real estate or they're doing
hiking or they're doing so it's like
niches right
um
we do tech
but
on the whole other side of the coin
i think that are you on tick tock
i think that tick tock
merged with youtube shorts
is
a
major strategy for you
i think asking yourself
what videos on youtube shorts and tiktok
are getting a hundred thousand
five hundred thousand views a million
views that you could
imitate in your own creative way and you
start making those
i think it start you start asking
yourself like trying harry potter snacks
is
a very
good like it just seems perfect for me
seems on brand for me
my thought is
uh
okay
looks like there's music here the music
is not right
not loud enough for me
so it's studying
the energy
the editing
of
uh the cop videos
that are getting so we're here at the
wizarding world of harry potter i'm
actually smiling so great i'm really
excited
oh god okay that's kind of cool so
what's what's the editing what's the
jump cuts what's the the different
aspects what's the lighting let me see
here
you try the classic chocolate and and of
course you know it's not it's not
comparison any kind of toxic way but
it's studying okay what are the top
videos
in some of these topics and what can i
learn from them and so just briefly i
skipped to the middle of this video
and was thinking and i mean i'm really
just making a snap judgment here but
like how could you maybe make it more
interesting or whatever because by the
way in my opinion this type of content
you stay at this and you get one percent
better with every upload now it's 600
views now you're going to have a
breakout video
around trying harry potter snacks
maybe it's
some tick tock trend aka youtube shorts
trend does that make sense and i'm sure
you're observing all that kind of stuff
can you see doubling down on that yeah
yeah
that's what i would do
and i think you got this and i think
it's that you know of course
this stuff takes work and it takes
mastery but you're you're out in georgia
because you're committed to your dreams
and you're um you're committed to
leveling up and getting better right
yeah
and so i think you got this i think
you're you'll see your youtube channel
rise you know your acting career rise
you know how competitive it is you know
how many people want to be in it but
you're hungry and you
uh
you also you're prayed up and you're
you're going after this thing and you're
also patient you've been consistent on
your youtube channel for three years so
now it's a matter of just saying okay i
got renewed focus renewed vigor um i am
gonna study what's happening i'm gonna
be true to myself and my own voice
and and again i feel this
it's no knowing that you're not going
down path to
is incredibly freeing and should give
you even more momentum to lean into path
number one
yeah because
it's not trying to be 14 things it's
trying to see like
this all ties together maybe not
perfectly but this all ties together so
i'm going to lean into this thing and
and triple down
on
entertainment industry
me the personal brand being entertaining
funny creative
skits
trends challenges
viral tick tock youtube shorts trends
and you haven't even posted a youtube
short yet have you
uh two of them oh you have youtube i
just i just put uh fancy uh thumbnails
on them so you can't tell because i got
it so i see that now and it has that one
of your most viewed videos
yes success leaves clues
youtube shorts youtube shorts around
food it's a whole thing
so
to
land the plane at this moment with what
what is happening with uh
those that are you know hungry and
really want this just like you
no pun intended hungry as we're looking
at these delicious pumpkin pasties
pastries
uh
they're some people are posting two
three shorts a day
you know what i mean yeah five days a
week
so it's like you got your two days to
you two days a week you promised me now
my cold
you promised me two days a week eight
hours a day but i'm holding you to that
because like if you want this it's like
you got your your three 12 to 15 hour
days you got your recovery i'm asking
you to grind i'm asking you to say i'm
gonna freaking hustle at this thing and
i'm gonna make
i'm gonna make
six shorts a week i'm gonna post there
i'm gonna schedule them for even the
days i'm working i'm gonna start being
super consistent i'm gonna study the
trends
you've got the acting chops you're
getting better at the acting chops and
you just completely and it's you're
gonna see a whole nother level of
momentum as you take all the skills and
of things you've absorbed up to this
point and then i'm going to put my
blinders on and focus on
you know not studying a million things
but like staying plugged into think
media and studying trends or whatever so
i'm not going to get into information
information overload right now that
doesn't matter i'm going to focus on my
entertainment career i'm going to focus
on doubling down on youtube
i'm going to limit my consumption and
not make it an excuse for research but i
do need to study the trends and i'm
going all in are you ready
yes
i am
all right joel i appreciate you thanks
so much for coming on thank you so much
sean
coffee candle what do you think hit the
like button tell me this if you've been
here the whole time give me a uh clock
emoji in the chat if you've been here
the whole time that's crazy you're
you're gnarly uh but in a good way uh
luciendo thanks for the super chat
growing up on youtube is harder than
graduating from university
i don't know what that question
really means but um
i mean going full time on youtube is
harder than graduating from university
maybe uh or just learning on youtube
hit me with the question if you're still
here again on on what's the difference
but i think there's probably challenges
to both
um
let me know though if you if you've been
here the whole time we got a lot of
people on the one hour and 44 minutes
stream i appreciate you redneck thanks
for coming on as well we got clocks
dropping
missed the first half hour of the
journey you're killing me i need you
here the whole time i'm just kidding
you're crazy for being here the whole
time but i hope you've been getting
value and here's my really important
question for you
what
was your aha moment from today
that
and more specifically what's your action
item
what are you going to do not just what
did you learn what are you going to do
not just what did you learn what are you
going to put into practice what are you
going to implement what are you going to
take action on
and
i see some clarity here
no i mean i would say i don't think that
i think that actually graduating it
depends on how you're wired
me trying to graduate from university
would be way more difficult than than
growing on youtube because
it would take just so much dang
coercion to try to get me to show up to
class and want to learn in that
environment compared to
you know expressing my creativity and
putting on youtube but
um growth on youtube
you know not to overly promote our class
but growth on youtube is hard when you
don't have the right strategy growth on
youtube is hard
when you are just when you're just being
random instead of intentional
growth on youtube is hard when you don't
really know where you're going because
if you don't know where you're going
then how are you going to know when you
get there so if you want to learn
about the types of videos you should be
making that will lead to growth
don't miss our free class that's
available for a few days it's at think
masterclass.com and you can watch that
replay but let's see uh
jump cuts tick tock come on coffee cake
strong strong
cut the fluff that was a big theme today
thanks for sharing that one getting one
percent better with every upload i like
it i like it
um
should we make shareable content then
still keep me making videos of what you
want it's a really good question because
or i like that you asked that question
because it act the answer is in the
question
that's actually up to you
should we make content that people want
to watch and share that will grow my
channel
or should i just keep making videos that
i want to make
what depends on what you want to happen
if you actually probably just keep
making videos that you want to make
and you don't care about growing
then you should just make whatever you
want to make it's your tube it's a place
where you just share your thoughts post
whatever you want
but if you actually want to like
make videos that get shared
then you should make videos that are
good [ __ ] should you make shareable
content and my answer
is actually
it depends on what your end goal is but
my answer is shareable content you
should make viewers you should make
videos where you think about the viewer
first and definitely that leans more on
sharing because hopefully
it starts generating growth and money
for the mission so you can keep making
more content if youtube is just your
diary
and just your place where you just share
your thoughts well then maybe that's the
goal of it but my friends we're coming
back to a common theme and that is
clarity right uh you're welcome thanks
for the follow-up super chat i really
appreciate you um
where
it's all about having a clear strategy
and a clear end goal
uh in terms of your channel and again
in this class at thinkmasterclass.com
by the end of it
you will have a simple youtube growth
plan plan i promise you it's a promise
of the class you will have a journal out
you will take notes i will tell you
exactly what videos you should make you
will filter that by your niche it is a
no miss class because you will leave
after 49 minutes
with a
simple game plan that you can implement
and that's at thinkmasterclass.com thank
you so much for the super sticker really
appreciate you
so many people been here the whole time
i really appreciate you being here for
coffee with kennel today
um and just so grateful for the love in
this community my friends this is coffee
with kennel we do this typically every
other week subscribe on the think media
podcast channel to be a part of these in
the future we'll be answering more
questions sharing more strategy if
you're just joining you're going to want
to watch the replay where we talk all
about that tool that will help you grow
on youtube a cool tool that'll help you
study your analytics from vid iq don't
miss
some of the content in
the description in terms of um
a free 30-day trial of vid iq as well as
a link to that free class that's only
available for a few more days and any
other resource we talked about the
description is always packed with
valuable information that will
help you go further faster it does look
like i missed a super chat from darlene
games
i am scrolling
my fingers about to cramp up from how
much i'm scrolling up in the chat but it
was a five dollar super chat
um i must scroll past it
and thank you so much for that
super chat oh oh oh oh oh oh okay
uh
i'll just read the question it is what
do you think about a gaming channel that
makes this live shorts and speed runs
should i include our all
i think that you um yeah you shouldn't
overthink it i think you can mix up your
content formats
here's the thing i want you to think
about darlene games and here's what i
want you to think about coffee with
kennel crew
um
what does the
viewer want from you
why did the viewer subscribe
here's my opinion i don't think viewers
subscribe for shorts they subscribe
for the type of content your channel
creates
like on think media they subscribe
because they want to learn about cameras
tech microphones and things like that
right
so here's my point
if that is done in a short
which on desktop we get a lot of shorts
viewers and people like them
because it's aligned with the promise of
the channel
if we go live
it's still to serve what the promise of
the channel is
and if we upload a video it's still to
serve what the promise of the channel is
so if you're creating you're asking
yourself who who am i serving
i'm serving gaming enthusiasts
people who want to watch gaming be
entertained by gaming
they want to watch a full speed run
great maybe you do a speed run
highlights and shorts that could work as
well maybe it's a real-time street speed
run on a live stream that could work as
well and maybe it's other thing related
to
what the viewer wants remember the
creator who understands the viewer best
wins
if you understand who you're talking to
they also don't necessarily know what
they want but if you understand
who they are
what they enjoy or the types of content
they enjoy then you might experiment
with something that they find intriguing
they try out and they want to watch it
if they click subscribe for gaming
content then it's probably more gaming
content they're probably not going to
want a gardening video because they'll
they'll go subscribe to a gardening
channel if that's what they want they
probably don't want to learn how to do
pour over coffee and watch you talk
about single origin coffee otherwise
they subscribe to a coffee channel but
inside
the clear vision of gaming content and
maybe a niche within that niche i think
you should experiment so the final
thought is that once you
understand the viewer
is it speed runs is it shorts is it
lives here's the next thing
watch the replay of this try everything
friends try it all
but then study
what worked and cut out what's not as
performing as well and then double down
on what is performing there's no black
and white answer
to
the gray area of growing on youtube
there's a lot of moving targets on
youtube that's why it's good to be
subscribed that's why we keep our course
video ranking academy updated that's why
tony does quick tips every single week
because
uh
he uh
there's always it's a moving target
he is that we're posting videos we're
getting one percent better and
then we're reviewing
the performance of our videos what
content should i double down on what
content should i stop doing what can i
learn what themes and patterns am i
seeing and that's what the topic of
today's coffee with kennel is check out
the vid iq tool at the beginning
that will go deeper in that as we land
the plane today thank you so much for
the super chat what is the best laptop
for editing the answer is ben g
kaiser
benji kaiser is one of our video rakit
academy students awesome guy and he's
got the greatest
uh
channel for computers and laptops in
terms of computers and laptops he
specializes in computers and laptops and
what i would do is i would go to his
channel i would type in video editing
and then it'll do is to take you 2021
best video editing laptops buyer's guide
for 1080p and 4k uh he's smart i trust
him and uh it's awesome to see so many
different video ranking academy students
crushing it
um and so
while i don't know the answer to that
question
i just passed you along to the expert
check out ben g kaiser on youtube and
check out his video
2021 best video editing laptops we'll
throw that in the description as well
coffee with kennel i appreciate you
grateful for you smash like here right
at the end of the show
and i look forward to seeing you in a
future episode peace